bella tutti ragazzi per un liquido io
sono per il j oggi siamo sugli appunti
da d'angolo tangled vengo a ciao bella
gnocca come stai
ho dovuto usare il joystick per sta roba
perché non è un tutorial una roba così
io non ci ho bisogno del tutorial per
giocare a videogiochi ragazzino io so
come cazzo si fa praticamente ragazzo
dovrebbe essere un gioco apre dunque ok
a figo dovrebbe essere una roba tipo 8
dead rega una roba molto simile molto
più intelligente soprattutto credo è una
che cos'è vero perché c'è una vecchia
che sta correndo con i soldi ragazzi e
bellissima perché ce l'avete seriamente
la vecchia ravera vai a prenderla dengo
del tuo momento ai mi chiamo d'angola
ragazzi padenghe che bello est bambina è
bellissima ragazza geniale a parte gli
scherzi
facciamo questo bambino giorno ascolta
cosa mi ha schivato come cazzo ci si
muove ancora ma cosa sta facendo
una roba o lei la madonna che velista
ragazzi break dance a tutti gli effetti
cioè io non è quella la vecchia cash la
roba ragazzi devo prenderla vecchia che
salve ok ragazzi cosa cazzo appena
succede ai bella gnocca dobbiamo andare
a controllare gli incidente si va bene
ha lanciato una banana non è possibile
qualcuno di voi mi deve spiegare come ha
fatto a far cappottare una macchina con
una banana impossibile madonna che ha
poliziotto smidollato che lo prendo
questo lo prendo
non ho preso ma cosa ragazzi questo
tizio braccio di ferro che bello
innocenti e gattini potrebbero essere
uccisi di portali nel camion alti
livelli di tornate nel camion per favore
no vieni qua io dico basta come faccio a
spingersi sono 400 gatti come li
spingono il camion io dio ragazzino no
al petrolio eva sono un [ __ ] i
vestiti li pulisce mamma è perché io non
la vedo dura perché sono pieno di
petrolio di verona braccino da
dall'amico tuo petrolio che bello
cosa sta diventato un uomo appiccicoso
col petrolio vieni qua bastardo [ __ ]
eccolo qua lo prese ragazzi e bellissimi
mi devo attaccare i gatti addosso per
metterli ma si può dai dai che d'attacco
anche poliziotto entrava l'edizione
questi sei atti ciò che diciamo che è
andata bene andiamo a comprare un po di
ciambelle
mio dio conosceva il caso delle docce
salvo poi essere attaccato al mio corpo
per sempre vuole che sono figure che ti
dai una pulita ma guarda io lo farei
volentieri dammi una doccia lo faccio
c'è un lavandino dove posso bulli o mio
dio ragazzi sto facendo drifting sono
pulito perfetto ragazzi è bellissimo
buongiorno ma serve perché c'è un ariete
o no
sembra che un cane capra il cane capra
sia forma è un ariete qualcosa sembra
che tu debba scavalcare questa
staccionata per scappare cioè adesso io
devo scavalcare staccionate perché ci
sono delle capre che mi vogliono
incornare mati in corno io ma [ __ ]
per giuro che ti lancio un bidone guarda
che è stronzo meglio lo faccio a ok a
posto bellissimo che non atto per
arrampicarmi ragazzi andiamo a prendere
le ciambelle cosa è successo saranno
tutto a fuoco fuoco ed è in gol dobbiamo
aiutare sì certo punto le ciambelle so
che non le prenderemo mai e camminata
sexy tyson
fratello a malapena sono capace di
camminare figurati senso spegnere un
fuoco prova beh ecco dobbiamo aiutarli
perché sta andando a fuoco quel tizio
cento non mi sembra chi è questo
qualcuno mi spiega il senso di questo
[ __ ] al gioco tolta mio zio non è che
vi spinga in mezzo alla strada che
magari ti investono e morì prima era
roba ma perché grossa continuando il
sentito lo rimetto qua va così a meno
secco perfetta ghazi scaleremo questa
montagna per spegnere il fuoco tanto
devo fare tutto io lei sta lanciando
degli oggetti
cosa sta lanciando un letto è una donna
quella lì mi sembra tipo un uomo
bruttissimi mai attento al vomito ma no
non ci posso mai credo ma che schifo è
amica mia ma che cazzo hai mangiato
fammi capire le ragazze impossibile come
faccio
cosa sta lanciando un pesce io sto
venendo ad aiutarti e tu milan ci la
roba
miley dice guarda che non riesco lo
stereo mi ha preso uno stereo in faccia
perfetta ok dai dai mio dio l'ultimo ce
la puoi fare se c'è cielo quattro
ragazzi questa torre è stata una roba
orribile non voglio mai più fare una
cosa del genere sommesso 40 minuti per
scalare un [ __ ] tetto cosa vuoi che
faccia
dove devo aprire la roba qua la vecchia
ma che cup che capelli ciani st ciotola
sono il figlio non è saltato in aria ma
almeno ha salvato l'edificio è successo
cos'è ma dove ha vinto vecchie bici è
questa
decolla ragazzi o non ho mai visto
decollare un aereo così io ve lo dico
però va bene lo stesso cioè lei sta
scappando
si vabbè ma come farlo è una vecchia
dobbiamo trovare un modo per fermarla
come la fermiamo hai acquisito la
pistola
la pista è variamente ma non ci crederò
mai nella vita
fermi a ragazzi fermi nati o troppo la
cosa più [ __ ] della storia attaccati
all'aereo dove mi alta quale aereo che
non lo vedo ma veramente posto mamma
l'ho preso non ci credo a bassa è
diventato il mio gioco preferito in
assoluto regalini kovar star da mamma
l'ho presa
l'ho preso l'ho presa subito legale ma
perché
e sa perché no sono già caduto hayden e
veloce veloce lo mancata suona mira che
minchia manco l'ippopotamo mai cosa
entrato mi si vede solo il braccio
fantastici o fatta ce l'ho fatta cosa
sto facendo
se un figo forza forza no
bravo no cosa stai facendo con
quell'equilibrio ti stai tenendo
esattamente bailo presa dovrei brutta
giorni vedi zia mi stai vedendo nella
tua fine si è già fatta siete pronti
ragazzi non so come si sta tenendo
esattamente in piedi ma va bene così ho
vinto ho vinto ho vinto io bra bra
perfetto bel [ __ ] adesso buttati
col paracadute perché non lo so che lo
farà
è una vecchia sprint quest'anno fra non
mi prenderei mai se ho capito ma come
hai fatto a sopravvivere perché sono su
un carrello
devo andare o mio dio oh mio dio non
regga la cosa più [ __ ] che abbia mai
visto
dentro demoni bags for speed most che
devo parlare o prendere questi per
essere più veloce lo chiedi ragazze la è
la cosa più bella che abbia mai visto
comandando un carrello a reazione che
non ho la più pallida idea di dove
l'abbia preso ma va bene così oh mio dio
mio dio guarda la madonna cui si
destreggia come si destreggia mi chiama
velocissima st vecchia come cazzo fate
arrivare fin qua no si va donna che però
guarda
schivo di dubbia ecco la vecchia eccola
ecco la lamentela vedo ora è 2 ore 21
rai due va a fan culo perfetta pesca
sorpresa ragazzi sono stato trasportato
nell'iperspazio cosa è successo shell ha
un senso questo gioco a parte gli
scherzi è finita è finita la demo
perfetto prima di finire volevo vedere
se riuscivo a prendere qualcuno a parte
ma devi morire lo prete niente non giova
comunque ragazzi mi fa piacere che ci
siano giochi così non senza ancora
perché complimenti proprio no veramente
il proprio bello dai chiodo ragazzine
che posso concludere che i video sono
andato al cimitero mi sono sepolto vivo
quindi ragazzi spero che ha visto vi sia
piaciuto scusate sarà un po corto ma era
una demo ma dovevo assolutamente
provarlo perché credo che sia il gioco
dell'anno ma non ne sono sicuro che
comunque ragazzi se il video è piaciuto
al solito lasciato questo mi piace anche
a pagina di facebook e come non i video
trovata descrizione prestiti sky ci
vediamo al prossimo vito bella ragazzi